JASON KU: I'm Jason.
Hopefully you guys
saw me on Tuesday.
This is our first ever
6.006 problem session
that we'll be having
on Fridays this term.
It's really an experiment.
We've never done this before.
But one of the things that we
were discussed while preparing
for this class is that we
have two different methods
of instruction, formally,
usually in this class--
a lecture, which is
there to present you with
the fundamental material,
the data structures,
and the algorithms that are the
base, the foundation of what--
how you will be approaching
problems in this class;
and then the problem sets
that you will work on,
our applications
of that material.
But there's usually
a much different feel
between those problems
that we'll give you then
the underlying
foundational material.
So the application
of that material
will feel very different.
And a lot of times,
there are tricks
to approaching the problems
or ways of approaching
the problems that
you kind of just
have to figure out by
working on the problem,
sometimes going to office hours.
But what we want to
do this term was to--
since we had the opportunity
to be recorded by OCW,
was to record us going
through some problems
that we've had on
problem sets in the past
so you could see how
we would approach
working on these problems
that you'll be working on,
at least in a similar vein.
So that's the goal of
these problem sessions.
In the past, for OCW, we
have recorded a recitation,
but we felt that that was
a little less useful to you
guys, because
recitation is meant
for interaction, questions--
one-on-one questions.
We want to be a safe
space for you guys
to interact with
the material with--
in a smaller environment
that might not be recorded.
So that's the goal of this--
these sessions that we
will be doing on Fridays.
Any questions about what
we're going to be doing today?
OK.
So we do have a handout up
here by the door, which we may
or may not have in the future.
This is all an
experiment, so you'll
have to work with us as
we figure this stuff out.
They were posted on LMOD about
an hour before this session.
We'll try to keep
that as a standard.
But it just shows
you the questions
we'll work on today
in the session.
It isn't just the problem
set from last term.
It's a selection of problems
from previous terms,
and some of them
have been edited
to be maybe a little shorter
and things like that.
So what we're
going to do is just
go through the
problems one by one.
I'll try to just show you how
I'm approaching the problems,
but at any point, if you want
to, you can ask questions.
That's fine.
OK?
All right, so the first
question we have is--
has a setup that's
very similar to what
you will have on your Pset1.
It's essentially saying that
it has usually many parts.
This has two parts, an
A part and a B part.
I've omitted a B
and a C that that
was on last term's problem set.
And it has five functions
each, and you're trying
to order them increasing as--
based on their
asymptotic behavior.
So here are the
functions that we have.
Maybe I'll stick it up instead.
All right, so we have a
few sets of functions,
and we just want to order them.
And some of the functions may
be asymptotically equivalent--
in which case, when we
are ordering these things,
we're going to put
those numbers in a set.
So what we have as an
example are three functions--
n, root n, and n plus root n.
This is one, two, three.
And what we're going
to ask you to do
is order those functions based
on their asymptotic complexity.
So hopefully you guys
can get this one.
Which one's the slowest
growth in terms--
root n, so number two.
So if we say f of 2
will be our first one.
And then, how about
the other two?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: They're the same.
They're both order n.
So we would put in set
brackets f1 and f3.
And on your problem set, if you
put just 2, and 1, and 3 here,
that would probably be fine.
But if you were to
put 2 over here or not
have these curly
braces around here,
those would not be correct, and
you'd get points marked off.
Does that make sense?
OK, so we're going to approach
the first set of problems--
first set of functions,
which is a little
different than the
second set of functions.
Hopefully this one's
a little easier.
One of the common
approaches that I have
in going through these things--
some of these are in a
form that is hard for me
to tell how they would
compare to other things.
Actually, most of these
are fine, but in general--
can anyone, just by
eyeballing, tell me
an order that works for them?
Yeah?
STUDENT: OK--
JASON KU: This is
a little difficult
to do on the spot
with five functions.
STUDENT: Yeah.
A little iffy about f1.
JASON KU: OK.
STUDENT: But f5 is definitely
smaller than f2, which is--
smaller than f2 which
is smaller than f4.
And f1 in iffy.
JASON KU: OK, great.
That's excellent.
So what we've got here
is, on f2, f3, and f5,
you kind of have
this n leading term.
If we factor an n out of that,
then we're comparing log with--
basically, we look over here
at the polynomial function.
This one's smallest out of
them, and then the log factor
is smaller than a
polynomial factor.
Log grows slower than linear.
And so this guy is smaller
than f2 is smaller than f3.
That's great-- that
your colleague said.
Hopefully proved in
recitation today--
no, Wednesday-- this nice fact,
I guess, that a is less than,
asymptotically,
this polynomial--
this log n to any power
is asymptotically less
than any polynomial for
any positive a and b.
And in particular, there's
actually a stronger thing
you can say, which is little o.
Did you guys talk about
little o in recitation at all?
Probably not.
It's kind of the same as big
O, except is big O minus theta.
So things that are
asymptotically equivalent
are not going to be
included in this set.
So actually, these
things are strictly
asymptotic-- grow
strictly asymptotically
slower than any polynomial.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So knowing this identity,
or this relation,
can we say anything about f1?
Maybe someone else--
STUDENT: Any a and b, right?
JASON KU: Any a and b--
any positive a and B--
anyone else have a guess?
Yeah?
STUDENT: That f1
is less than f5--
JASON KU: Yeah, f1 is
less than f5, right?
Because just using that
identity, this-- sorry--
a here that erased, stupidly,
is smaller than, say--
this is bigger than n, and n
to the b, being 1, is bigger.
And then, as your colleague
pointed out before,
this thing is exponential,
so definitely higher
than a polynomial.
OK, so that was
very easy, right?
So the answer here
is, if I got--
if I remember correctly, f1,
f5, f2, f3, and then f4--
great.
So that one was pretty easy.
How about b-- or d, I guess?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Can I just
another question--
JASON KU: Sure.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] How would
you go about proving that?
JASON KU: How would you
go about proving that?
So there is a proof in your
recitation handout there.
The method in which they proved
that in the recitation handout
was putting the two--
taking a ratio of
the two functions
and taking their limit
as n goes to infinity.
And if the top one--
it grows arbitrarily, then
the top one would be--
grow asymptotically faster.
And if the it went
to 0, the bottom one
would grow
asymptotically faster.
And if it went to
some constant, then
that would be
asymptotically equivalent.
Does that make sense?
In actuality, to make
the limit easier to take,
we take the limit of the
logarithm of the ratio.
It just made it easier.
Does that makes sense?
OK, so let's move on to b.
b-- we have a polynomial,
and an exponential,
and then we have these
things down here.
What do these things
in parentheses mean?
STUDENT: Choose.
JASON KU: Choose, right.
It's a binomial coefficient.
Does anyone know the
binomial coefficient is?
Yeah?
Hopefully from
6.042 or something
like that, or whatever
your competition math
background is--
but in general, we
have this definition.
This thing is what?
Does anyone remember?
What does n choose k mean?
Yeah?
STUDENT: The number of ways
to choose k objects from n
[INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah, the
number of ways to choose
k objects from n things--
I never remember this formula.
And probably, a lot of you
have memorized this formula.
I'm not going to
ask you to do it.
I'm going to tell you
how I think about this.
What if I want to know the
number of permutations of n
choose k-- or I mean of n?
Sorry.
Just how many permutations
are there of n items?
What is that?
That's just n factorial, right?
So what we do here is
we'd want to choose
some n number of things.
I have n factorial different
ways of choosing those,
but then, essentially, in here
and in here, k and n minus k--
I don't really care
what their order is.
So I'm going to divide
out the permutations
of this stuff and this stuff.
Does that makes sense?
So the formula here
as I remember it,
that hopefully is correct,
is n minus k factorial.
So I'm getting all of the
permutations of the whole thing
divided by their constituents.
Does that make sense?
Did I do that right?
OK, cool-- so that's
a nice transformation.
So the first step is writing
these in terms of factorials.
That doesn't really help me
any, because I don't know
how big factorial is based--
with respect to
these other things.
Does anyone know how
big factorial is?
Yeah?
STUDENT: You can use
Sterling's approximation.
JASON KU: You can use
So that's nice.
Does anyone remember what
Sterling's approximation is?
No.
I don't remember either.
I always have to look it up.
Sterling's approximation says
n factorial is approximately--
and this approximately
is much stronger
than an asymptotic behavior.
It's actually, as these things--
as n approaches infinity,
these things are equal.
The limit is the identity.
But the approximation
is the square root
of 2 pi n n/3 to the n.
OK, that's fun.
So what kind of growth is this?
Super bad, right?
It's definitely exponential
or higher than exponential.
It's n to the n--
something like that--
dividing out an e--
this is e, the base of
the natural logarithm.
And this is a
constant, and so is pi.
Pi is a constant--
kind of interesting
that we have two
transcendental numbers here.
That's kind of fun mathematics.
I'm sure some-- one of
your 6.042 instructors
could tell you why.
I can't right now off
the top of my head.
But this is an approximation
that's very good.
And actually,
sometimes other people
will think-- this is what people
call Sterling's approximation.
One weaker notion that
sometimes is useful for you
is, if you take the
logarithm of both sides,
this is asymptotically what?
If I took the log
of this thing--
STUDENT: Polynomial--
JASON KU: It is a
polynomial thing.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: It's
basically n log n.
If we take a log of this thing,
it would be various things.
All right, let's do it out.
2 pi n n/e to the n--
so when we're inside a
logarithm, multiplication--
we can split it out--
becomes addition.
Division becomes subtraction.
And this thing grows faster
than all these other things,
so we can ignore them when we
add them out asymptotically.
And so what we end up
getting is this n to the n.
The n comes out
on the logarithm,
and you get something
that's theta n log n.
Oh, that's fun.
This is something we might
use later on in the class.
OK, but when we are
comparing these functions,
one of the nice things
to do is convert them
into something
that's familiar to us
so that we can
compare them easily.
So here, this thing is
whatever that thing is, roughly
square root n n/e to the n.
This is, I'm going
to say, theta.
That's a little
bit more precise.
All right, then what
about these two things?
Let's start with the bottom one.
Can someone tell me what
this is, asymptotically?
Yeah?
STUDENT: n cubed--
JASON KU: n cubed--
why is that?
Well, if we plug this stuff
into that definition here,
we have n factorial over 3
factorial n minus 3 factorial.
n factorial over n
minus 3 factorial
just leaves us with
an n, an n minus 1,
and an n minus 2 over 6.
And if you multiply
all that out,
the leading term is an
n cubed, so this thing
is asymptotically n cubed.
I skipped some steps,
but hopefully you
could follow that.
And then the last thing to
remain is this one right there.
That one's a little tricky.
Anyone want to help me out here?
What we can do is we can
stick it into this formula,
and then apply
Sterling's approximation
to replace the factorials.
That makes sense?
OK, so what I'm going to do is--
let's do this in two steps.
This is going to be
n factorial over--
what is this? n/2
factorial-- and then
what is n minus n over 2?
That's also n/2.
So this is going to be
n/2 factorial squared.
Is that OK?
Yeah?
Now let's replace this stuff
with Sterling's approximation
and see if we can simplify.
So on the top, we have 2
pi n n/e to the n over--
and then we've got
a square here, pi n.
I cancelled the 2--
n/2 over e to the n/2.
Did I do that right?
OK.
I can't spell, and
a lot of times,
I make arithmetic errors, so
catch me if I am doing one.
OK, so let's simplify
this bottom here.
I'm not going to
rewrite the top.
The bottom here--
we square this guy.
It's the pi times n.
And then this guy, n/2 squared--
that just stays is an n.
Then we have n/2 to the n/e--
something like that. n/2 over
e to the n-- that makes more--
me happier.
OK, so now we have
this over this.
How do we simplify?
Well, we can cancel out
one of the root n's.
So we've got square root of pi
n down here and square root of 2
up top.
And then what have we got?
We've got n to the n down here
and n to the n down-- up there,
so those cancel.
We got 1 over e to the n,
1 over e to the n up there.
Those cancel.
What's left in this term,
when-- after we cancel?
1 over 2 to the n in the
denominator, which is
2 to the n in the numerator--
so this thing is what
this thing is right.
Asymptote.
We can get rid of
these constants.
And it's root n--
I mean, it's 2 to the n
over root n, asymptotically.
Does that makes
sense, everybody?
OK.
With that knowledge-- and I'm
sorry for my messy board work--
what is the ordering of
these functions then?
Can someone help me out?
Someone else-- Eric, I'm sorry.
You can't answer.
Come on, guys.
You followed what I said.
Start it out for me.
STUDENT: I think [INAUDIBLE]
f2 and f5 [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Right.
So both of these things are
asymptotically equivalent,
so we should put
those in brackets--
f2, f5.
STUDENT: And then
it would go f--
[INAUDIBLE] 3.
JASON KU: f3.
This one?
Why this one?
STUDENT: Nevermind.
JASON KU: I'm just asking you
to justify what you're saying.
STUDENT: Well, because I feel
like we have the [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Uh-huh.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: This
one's the biggest?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: f4 is
the biggest, right?
So this one's definitely
bigger than this,
because it's n to the n,
as opposed to 2 to the n.
So for any n larger
than 2 plus e
is fairly obvious
that that's bigger.
STUDENT: So wouldn't
f3 be before f1?
JASON KU: Why would
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] 2 to
the n divided by [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: But we're dividing
by a polynomial factor, right?
So it's going to be
slower asymptotically
than the first one right there.
So you got it right.
What is it?
F3, f1, and f4--
OK?
Cool-- so it's a
little complicated,
but just applying some
logarithm an exponent rules,
understanding that logarithmic
factors grow slower
than polynomial ones,
and again, grow slower
than exponential ones.
And being able to do some
transformations of some
of these mathematical
quantities to get them
in a polynomial-like
looking form
is how you're going to
approach these problems.
Does that make sense?
All right, so we're going to
move on to question 2 now.
Yeah, you've got a question?
STUDENT: Yeah, I
have a question.
What did you say the
theta bound was for 4?
JASON KU: Theta bound for 4?
This guy?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: So it's just that.
I don't know how to
simplify that any further.
You've got a
polynomial factor here,
and then this is an n to the n
term divided by an exponential.
Yeah?
STUDENT: For f3,
which one did you--
how did you reduce--
which one is f3 [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: f3 took this
little cycle here.
What we did was we
expanded out the definition
of the binomial
coefficient here.
Then we applied
Sterling, and then we
simplified and got back.
Does that make sense?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Sure.
STUDENT: Is there a reason
that f3 is before f1?
JASON KU: Why is f3 before f1?
If I erase the 2 and the pi,
this thing is theta of that--
2 to the n over a
polynomial factor.
It's over n to the 1/2.
n to the 1/2 grows
non-trivially.
Right?
And so this is going to decrease
the running time of this thing
by a polynomial factor.
You could think about--
we're multiplying this by
n to the minus 1/2 as well.
That's another way
of thinking about it.
Any other questions?
OK, so we're going to move
on to problem 2, I guess.
I need a eraser.
So problem 2 is kind of
a funny looking problem.
The point of this
problem is to get
you to think about using
some of the things we're
going to be using in this
class as a black box.
What using something
as a black box
means is that has a kind of a
public interface that you're
allowed to work with,
but I'm not allowed
to see what's inside of it.
And a lot of times, what
we'll do in this class
is try to use a
black box and just
try to use the abstracted
outer functions so that we
can prove things about it.
We can just accept
those as true,
and then use those to
deal with our analysis.
So what we're given
in this problem
is a data structure supporting
a sequence interface
that you heard about yesterday.
What's a sequence
interface again?
How does it store items?
Anyone remember?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Well, it--
OK.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: All right.
So what your colleague
is saying here
is we list them in
a contiguous array.
Does anyone have a problem
with that definition?
Yeah, up there--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: OK.
So one of the important
things about this class
is abstracting this
idea of an interface
versus an implementation.
And so what this student
down here was talking
to me about an array as an
underlying implementation,
and what the student back
there was talking about
is a linked list.
These are both things that
can implement that interface.
But in reality, the interface
is something abstracted outside
of those ideas.
We could implement with either
of those data structures.
So what makes the sequence
interface a sequence interface?
Yeah?
STUDENT: It's in
order, or at least it's
indexed in a specific way
that allows for [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: So it's about the
data that we're storing.
We're storing some
number of things,
and the important thing
is that the data structure
is maintaining being
able to find items
in that set by maintaining
an order on them.
I usually like to call
it an extrinsic order
on these things.
It has nothing to do
with what the items are.
It has to do with how
I put them in order.
There's a first thing,
there's a 10th thing,
there's a last thing.
Right?
That's what a sequence
of items is right.
And so what this
data structure is
doing, that's the input that
is what we have available to us
in this problem, is some
kind of data structure
storing a sequence of things.
And it can support
these four operations--
an insert first, insert last,
delete first, and delete last.
And it supports each of those
things in constant time.
You don't a data structure
that does that yet.
You will on your
problem set 1, and we'll
talk about another
way to do that today.
But we don't care
how it's implemented.
We just give you this black
box that achieves these things.
Yay-- awesome.
And so what we're trying to
do is, we have this thing,
and I want to be able to
manipulate the sequence stored
inside, but all I have access to
are these external operations.
So the idea is going to be
let's implement algorithms
for these-- some
higher level operations
in terms of these lower level
things that are given to us.
Does that makes sense?
And this is actually a
pretty easy question.
Hopefully we'll have slightly
more difficult ones for you
on--
in a different context
on problem set 1.
OK, so the first operation
we're going to support--
or try to support--
is an operation
called swap_ends.
And what this is going to do
is take the data structure
that we gave--
another way you could do this
is put this as a method on that
data structure, but let's
do this separately--
it's going to take that data
structure that we gave--
that I gave you, that's
storing the sequence,
as the only argument.
And what we're
asking you to do is
describe an algorithm to swap
the first and the last items.
I it was an array, I could just
look at index 0, look at that,
look at the last one look
at that, and swap them.
But I don't have access to what
that underlying representation
is, so how would I do that
using the things that we
have available to us?
This is a pretty easy question.
What have we got?
STUDENT: Just a quick question.
JASON KU: Yeah.
STUDENT: Does the delete
method also return
whatever it deletes?
JASON KU: Yes.
Yes, it does.
So in general, if you actually
take a look at the session
notes, it's giving you
a nice little reminder--
recall, the delete operations
return the deleted item.
OK?
It says it right
there on the thing.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Oh, I also
had a question.
JASON KU: Sure.
STUDENT: And this
actually [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Mm-hmm.
STUDENT: It's not
related [INAUDIBLE]
if they don't specify a space
[INAUDIBLE] does that mean
[INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah, so
one of the things
that Eric talked about yesterday
was generally, in this class,
if you have--
usually what we'll give
you is a running time
bound on the things
that you asked for.
And because allocation
of space by our model
takes that amount of
time, the amount of time--
the amount of space
that we are using
is going to be asymptotically
upper bounded by the time
that we're going to
use for the algorithm.
And so generally, we'll ask you
to stay within a time bound,
and not ask you to do
something separate with space,
but there are problems probably
at the end of this unit
where we might talk
about space complexity.
But usually, we will
be very specific
if we want you to
think about space.
Any other questions?
All right, so how do we
implement this swap_ends thing?
Yeah.
This is a pretty easy one.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] say
first equals [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: OK, so another
thing about this class--
your colleague
over here is trying
to write code to me, which
is great for a computer,
and that's great if
you're taking 6.009.
It's not great if you're
talking to your friends
or if you're talking to me.
I can't parse code in my head
and compile it all the time.
Sometimes I can, but
not all the time,
especially when it gets
to be a large program.
So I want you to
explain in words to me,
and we want you to explain in
words in your LaTeX submissions
what it is the
algorithm is doing.
So can you start over
with your description?
STUDENT: Words are hard.
JASON KU: Words are hard.
I agree with you.
STUDENT: This is a
computer science class.
STUDENT: I would delete
the last [INAUDIBLE]
and then take that
value [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: OK.
So proposal-- we have
a sequence of things.
Again, as Eric was doing
in lecture yesterday,
this isn't
representing an array.
It's representing a sequence.
So this is the front
first I guessed and last.
And what your colleague was
saying was to delete this guy
and stick it on the front,
maybe by using delete last
and insert first.
That sounds pretty good.
Does that do what
swap_ends is doing?
Swap_ends-- swap the first and
last items in the sequence.
STUDENT: It's probably
better if we first store it
in some other variable, so that
way we can get the-- delete
the n [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: So what your
colleague is saying is,
well, we've done kind
of half of our work.
The first one's still over here.
That's no good.
Does someone have a
way to modify this?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Before modifying,
you can [INAUDIBLE] to modify.
[INAUDIBLE] about the amount
of things we're storing.
JASON KU: Yeah.
So how much extra space
can we use, for example?
STUDENT: The
easiest way would be
to delete the last
[INAUDIBLE] the first,
and then just, if we have
them already kept [INAUDIBLE]
but I don't know if I can
keep two different variables
at the same time.
JASON KU: Good question--
so the question-- can I
use additional space?
And in general, if
we don't give you
any restrictions on what you
can store, then you can go wild.
Do whatever you want, outside
of this data structure.
One of the things you
could do is remove first
all of these things, store
it and some data structure
you like, manipulate
it as much as you want,
and then insert first
all the way back in
and rewrite the thing.
But that's not going to
give us constant time, which
is what we're asking for.
But if we don't tell you
otherwise, feel free to--
probably, you're only allowed
to store a constant number
of things, since we
have constant time,
but generally, unless
we say, no, you
can't use additional space,
you can use additional space.
OK?
So how would you do that?
STUDENT: I would probably erase
the last one and the first one,
keep them both, then
answer the first one,
answer everything else, and
then answer the last one.
JASON KU: That's great.
So what your
colleague is saying--
we delete both of them, we store
them in temporary variables,
and then, one at a time,
we insert each of them
in their corresponding
place using the functions
that we have available.
OK, so if I were to write
little pseudocode for this,
I might take the first one--
I'd delete first.
I'm really abusing
notation here.
That's OK.
You get what I'm saying.
Delete the last,
and then store them
in their respective places.
Insert at the front--
which one am I going to insert?
What's up?
Speak up, guys.
STUDENT: x2--
JASON KU: x2-- yes.
Thank you.
And insert last, x1--
OK, that's pretty easy.
Yeah?
STUDENT: In this
case, what would
[INAUDIBLE] I think
this might be relevant.
[INAUDIBLE] What would
constitute a pseudocode
versus [INAUDIBLE]
accidentally writing
Python syntax [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: All right,
so for this problem,
you'll see the solutions
posted to this later on.
In that one, I wrote
up a description
of what I was going to do, and
then I actually-- because this
was pretty easy, I actually
wrote down some Python code
to do whatever this thing was.
But in general--
and it's actually
OK to write Python or pseudocode
of this form on your problem
sets, or on an exam,
or something like that.
But if we can't understand
what your variables mean,
if we can't understand what
your pseudocode is doing,
then that's not sufficient.
So the reason why
we ask for words
is so that you can
communicate those ideas well.
STUDENT: Just a
follow-up on that--
so can you also
have a combination
of pseudocode and description?
JASON KU: Sure.
STUDENT: OK.
JASON KU: Yeah--
including both of them
can be clarifying
for you, potentially.
Any other questions?
This is not such an
interesting question
from an algorithm standpoint.
This is a constant
size problem kind of.
I have this data structure.
I do two operations.
I need to do something.
And this is so easy that
I'm really not even going
to argue correctness--
I'm not even going to
have to argue correctness
to you, because we're
essentially just doing
exactly what we asked for.
Most of the time in this class,
when you're doing something
non-trivial-- especially when
you're doing something that
has to recurse in
some way-- we do
want you to argue correctness.
But in this case, for example,
the time analysis is very easy.
We do for operations.
They each take constant
time, so this operation
takes constant time--
done.
Yeah?
All right, so how about
the second operation?
Second operation at least allows
us to use a little bit more.
So
Shift_left D, K-- this is the
operation we're supporting now
is we are given this sequence,
and what we want to do is take
the first K, here and stick it
over here at the back so that
the--
these K go here.
So the K-th item ends
up being the last item
and the K plus 1th item
now becomes the first item.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
Again, this is actually not
such an interesting algorithm
from an algorithm standpoint,
but it's hopefully
helpful to talk about from an
instructional point of view.
OK?
So how would I
approach this problem?
I need this operation to
happen in order K time.
Yeah?
STUDENT: OK.
So first, go and delete--
set a variable x1 to be the
d dot delete first element.
Then do d dot insert at the
last x1, write a for loop,
and then do that K times.
And that should take
2K steps, which is OK.
JASON KU: OK.
So what your
colleague was saying
is that we're just going
to delete this guy,
stick it on there,
do it K times.
That sound good?
Yeah.
One of the things in this
class that you have, in terms
of implementation--
usually there are two ways--
at least two ways you
could do something
that takes longer
than constant time.
You could write a four loop
where you could use recursion.
Sometimes approaching a
problem would be good one way,
rather than another.
Why is it that a lot
of computer scientists,
as opposed to coding
engineers, prefer to think
about an algorithm recursively?
Does anyone know why?
At least I do, when
I'm explaining it
from a theory standpoint.
It actually might not be
good from an implementation
standpoint, because your
computer can vectorized
for loops and things like--
but that's not something
we need to talk about.
Why would we want to talk
about a recursive algorithm
maybe more?
STUDENT: It lets you break up
the problem into much smaller,
more manageable pieces.
JASON KU: OK, so recursion
lets you break up the problem
into small measurable pieces.
That's actually true
in some context.
How I like to think about
recursion a lot of times is,
if I have a non-constant amount
of work that I have to do,
usually easy for me--
it's hard for me to hold
a non-constant amount
of information in my head.
What I want to do is think
about a constant amount
of information at any
given point in time,
because that's easier
for me to argue on.
It's easier for me to think
about making arguments, case
analysis on these
small amount of things.
And so one of the
things you can do
is, if you break it down
so that I solve a slightly
smaller problem
recursively, and then
do a constant amount of work
and maintain some invariant,
then it's very easy to
argue things about it.
It's very easy for
me to convince myself
that this thing's correct.
So I'm going to
provide a recursive way
of solving this problem.
Can anyone set up
maybe a recursive way
of thinking about this
problem, instead of
putting this inside a for loop,
like your colleague was saying?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
people do is
just consider what will happen
when k equals 0 you're not
[INAUDIBLE] it at all.
JASON KU: OK.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
what it originally was.
And then-- but if that
k is greater than 0,
you just [INAUDIBLE] and
then [INAUDIBLE] k is 1 less
[INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: So what your
colleague is saying
is setting up the--
a very nice thing.
She's saying that, if we
think about this recursively,
we'll think about a base case--
which, your colleague was
saying maybe K equals 0.
And otherwise, if
we're not at 0,
what we'll do is we'll start
it out, move one of these guys
over, and then we have
an instance where we want
to shift K minus 1 things over.
Want to do the same thing,
but with K minus 1 things.
And so we can just call this
thing for a smaller value
of K. Does that makes sense?
All right, so let's
try to write that out.
The first thing I'm going to
write out is kind of a break.
If I'm at a base case, let's
not do anything to this thing.
And maybe I also
want some bounce
checking to make sure
that we're in range.
OK, so I'm going to say,
if our K is less than 1,
I don't think we should be
doing anything to this array.
So let's just not do anything.
If K is less than
1 or K is bigger
than the length of D minus
1-- so I don't know what
to do if you're asking me to
shift more than the things I
have, so let's not do that.
Yeah-- because if
it was length of D,
we would just not
move anything anyway,
because we'd shift
the whole thing.
So we don't have to do anything.
All right.
If we're in either
of these cases,
we're just going to return,
because I either shouldn't
do anything to the array
or I have no idea what
you're talking about,
if it's negative
or something like that.
OK, so that's the first thing.
Otherwise, what do we do?
We shift one thing over and
then we make a recursive call.
Does that make sense?
OK.
So we'll delete the first
thing as a temporary variable--
delete first.
And then we'll insert last, x.
And then we need to
do the recursive call.
So what's a recursive
call look like?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Shift_left
D, K minus 1--
JASON KU: Yeah.
So shift_left D, K minus 1--
OK?
And then we can return.
This thing doesn't need
to return anything.
It's just doing
stuff to the thing.
Right?
And whenever we
get this K, we make
a call, that gets down
to 0, we will terminate
because we will return.
We're in this range
somewhere between we--
have an input after this line.
We know that K is somewhere
between 1 and n minus 1.
And what we'll do is, every
time through this recursion,
we will subtract 1
from K. So this is
a nice, well-ordered sequence.
We do the correct thing
obviously in the base case,
and as long as this thing
was correct for a smaller
value of K, this thing also
does the correct thing,
because we're shifting
over one, as we are asked,
and we're letting this
do the work of the rest.
I don't have to
think about that.
I just have to think about
this one loop, this one part
of the thing that I'm doing.
Constant amount of work
is done in this section.
And how many times
do I call a function?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
I think K minus 1 times, or--
I don't know.
I forget.
But it's ordered
K for sure, right?
And we do a constant
amount of work per call,
ignoring this extra call.
Does that make sense?
So this thing runs in
order K, as desired.
OK?
Does that make sense?
All right.
So now we will move
on to question 3.
Any questions about question 2?
That one's really probably
one of the easiest problems
we've ever had on a problem set.
Sorry to scare you.
So problem 3--
OK, so this is a little
block of text right here.
A dynamic array can support
a sequence interface
supporting worst case
constant time indexing
as well as insertion
and removal of items
at the back of the array
in amortized constant time.
So this is what we did
yesterday in lecture, right?
We showed how a dynamic array--
it's fast to do dynamic
operations at the end.
OK.
However, insertion and
deletion at the front
is not very efficient because,
if you tried to do that,
you'd have to shift
everything over.
That makes sense?
All right, on the other hand,
what we talked about yesterday
was linked lists.
They can be made to support
insertion and deletion
at both ends in constant time.
OK, so that's a little
foreshadowing of something
you're going to do on Pset1.
But in lecture, we talked
about that operation--
that data structure,
a singly linked list,
being good at dynamic operations
at the front of the list,
because essentially,
we could just
remember where the
front of the list
was and swap things
in as needed.
That makes sense?
So on your problem set,
what you're going to do
is make end operations good
on the linked list as well,
as well as supporting
another operation.
But what's the problem
with linked lists,
as compared to dynamic arrays?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Linked list lookups
can take up to linear time.
JASON KU: Yeah,
linked lists lookups
can take linear time,
because I have no--
I don't have the benefit of
an array, where I can randomly
access something in the middle
by essentially just doing
one arithmetic
offset calculation
from the front address and be
able to find this thing further
down in constant time using
our model of computation
of the random net
access machine.
In a linked list,
these things could
be stored all over
the place in memory,
and I have to traverse those
pointers until I get to the one
that I'm looking for.
That's a benefit of
an array-based data
structure versus a
linked, pointer-based one.
OK, so then we get to the
meat of this question.
Show that we can have
the best of both worlds--
we can have a data
structure that
supports worst case
constant time lookup, just
like an array, but amortized
constant time dynamic
operations from the back and
the front of the sequence.
Does that make sense?
All right.
Is this question or a--
OK.
STUDENT: Can you define
amortize one more time?
JASON KU: Yes.
Sorry about that.
Can I define amortize
one more time?
OK, so this is a tough
thing to define in general,
but not that much.
All right, so amortization
usually you put in--
at least in this
class, we're going
to put in terms of
a data structure.
So you have this thing.
It supports some
operations, and you're
going to do a bunch of
operations on that thing.
There's not really a reason
to have a data structure,
unless you're going to
do lots of things to it.
Otherwise, you just
write a single algorithm
to do whatever it is
that you want to do.
The value of the
data structure is
that you can do
some work up front
by making this thing make some
of these operations faster.
OK?
So what amortization
means is, OK,
if I have, say, a
dynamic array, where
I'm going to be inserting
things at the end,
sometimes, when I
add something, I'm
going to spend a lot of
time to add that thing.
I'm going to spend linear time.
But what's the
point of this data
structure in the first place?
The point is that I want to
be able to potentially add
a lot of things to this thing.
Does that make sense?
Amortization is saying
that, even though sometimes
this operation will be bad,
averaged over many operations,
this is going to have
a better running time.
That's the amortization.
So more formally, what
that's going to say is,
if I have an operation, the
definition of it running
in amortized some amount
of time-- say K time or--
yeah, sure-- that means
that, if I do n operations,
generally for large N--
if I do that operation n
times, the total time it takes
me to do all of those
operations is not
going to be more than n
times K. So on average,
it's going to take me K time.
Now, in O-4-6 you'll get a
more formal definition of that
and you'll get a lot of
ways of analyzing things,
like a potential function and--
we're going to use in what
we call charging arguments
even today.
So it's a much broader
analysis paradigm
than what we're
going to talk about.
We're only going
to talk about it
for this material
with dynamic arrays,
and we'll just kind of--
it's just kind of an
introduction to that.
But does that make sense?
STUDENT: Yes.
JASON KU: Amortized as
a financial term, if you
know from financial term,
means over the long term,
this is what it is on average.
You can think about--
but that's different
than running time.
That's average running
time of an algorithm.
It's a much different concept.
What is an average running time?
Well, that's hard to
define, because it's
talking about an average over
all possible inputs, and then--
OK, so maybe some inputs
are more likely than others,
and so you've got a
distribution on the inputs
and you're trying to average
the running time of--
this has nothing
to do with that.
Amortization means that
you have a-- usually a data
structure that
you're operating on,
and you're doing an
operation multiple times,
and you're getting a
benefit because you're doing
that operation lots of times.
And so when you are
instantiating a Python list
and you're doing push and
pop operations on the back,
that's--
or is it append--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Append and pop?
OK.
I've been writing JavaScript
a little bit recently.
But so append and pop--
those operations, while
not cheap all the time,
are cheap well enough that, when
we analyze an entire algorithm
that might do a linear number
of appends to this list,
all of those appends
added together
will only take linear
time, because I've
done a linear number of them.
Does that make sense?
STUDENT: Yeah.
Thank you.
JASON KU: OK-- long-winded
answer to your question.
Sorry about that.
Any other questions
before we get going?
All right.
Anyone have any
ideas of how we can
use the ideas of a dynamic array
and make it good for operations
on both ends?
I'll let someone else answer.
I'll give a second, and
then go to you in a sec.
Yeah?
STUDENT: So [INAUDIBLE] dynamic
[INAUDIBLE] left true on one
end [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Sure.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] here we
could leave some [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: That's
an excellent idea.
We're going to talk about
two ways of doing this.
Right.
So what your colleague was
saying was that, in lecture,
when we're talking about
dynamic ways and we want to make
operations on the
right side-- the end--
fast, what we did was we
allocated some extra space
at the end, and then,
when we added things,
we didn't have to reallocate.
We had space to
put those things.
So what your colleague
was saying was,
let's just do the same
thing on both ends.
Let's leave some extra space
on the front and extra space
on the back when we
instantiate this thing,
and then we can rebuild
less frequently than if we
didn't have that extra space.
Does that makes sense?
OK, so what we had for,
let's say, down here--
so this is question 3--
the idea of the
dynamic array right
was that we left some
extra space here at the end
so that, sure, we allocated
more than we needed to,
but when we insert
things now, it's cheap.
And we don't have to allocate
more space for this thing
until we've done a linear
number of insertions.
This was n.
Really any constant
factor will do here.
But if you had n
things here, we'd
be assured that I
wouldn't need to rebuild
this thing until I've done a
linear number of operations.
And so in a sense, I can charge
the linear time operation
of re-expanding this thing to
each one of those operations.
And so on average,
it'll be constant.
Does that makes sense?
Right.
So instead, what your
colleague was saying--
let's instantiate this
thing with some extra space
on both sides.
OK?
So now, as I insert thing here,
insert thing here-- blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah--
I'll definitely know that, after
a linear number of insertions,
when I rebuild this
thing, I'll have
done enough operations to pay
for that expensive operation.
Does that makes sense?
So that's the idea behind
expanding this dynamic array
to be kind of this dynamic deck.
It's a doubly ended
queue kind of system
where I can do dynamic
operations efficiently
on both ends.
So one of the things that
we talked about yesterday
was also removing
right at the end.
Removing items from
the back of this thing
will decrease the number of
items we're storing, right?
That makes sense.
And maybe we're just
fine with that right.
As a programmer, why
might you not like
just removing items
until you got to nothing,
and just leaving the
space where it is?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Might lock up a
lot of memory [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
So let's say, over the
course of my program,
I use this data structure.
I'm just trying to
fill it up with stuff,
and then I remove all
but like two things,
and then I go about my business.
I run through the program.
But I'm never really using
any but those two things
for the rest of my program.
But now I've got--
I don't know-- maybe I did
put 1,000, or a million,
or a billion things in that
thing, and then, when I--
as I decreased, as I removed
things from that item,
I still have all that
space there being taken up
by essentially nothing, because
I've removed everything from
it--
at least in my conception.
So what I would really like
to maintain with this data
structure is that
at no point in time
am I using more than a
linear amount of space
with respect to the number of
things that are stored in it.
Does that make sense?
So in a dynamic
array, what we do
is, when we get small enough,
let's resize this thing down
so that we have--
we're using less space.
As I'm decreasing,
as I'm popping things
from the end of this
thing, at what point
do you think I should
rebuild my array?
When I'm no longer
a linear amount?
Well, that's a little hard to
tell what that is in real life,
because our ends
aren't arbitrary.
We need to actually have a time
at which we need to transition
over and copy things over.
So when might we
want to do that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Say again.
STUDENT: After n/2 [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: After n/2 removals--
OK.
So I remove n/2 things.
OK, so now we're kind
of at a n/4 fill--
so we're using a
fourth of the space.
And now-- great.
So you're saying rebuild.
OK, so I'll stick everything
in something that's now--
this is m.
I'm going to call
this m, and now we're
sticking it into something
that has size m/4.
Sound good?
Yeah?
Everyone OK with this?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
m/4 [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Oh, OK.
So what you're saying
is that we actually
want to keep some
extra space back here.
And why is that?
Because imagine if we just
allocated this amount of space,
and I removed the m/4
plus 1th item here,
we resized down to
this thing, and then I
want to do an insertion again.
Well, then I have to re expand
out to something like this,
and that's maybe not
going to be a good thing.
We might have to bounce
back and forth a lot.
That's hard for me to think
about what we're going to do.
But if we always resize
to a fill ratio that
includes a linear amount
of things on the end,
then I know that,
when I resize down,
I'll be doing either a
linear number of deletions
or a linear number of insertions
before I have to rebuild again.
So this charging
argument again--
I have to do a linear
number of cheap things
before I have to do an
expensive thing again.
OK?
So I resize down to be--
still keep a linear amount
of extra space at the end.
And with the double
ended thing, you
can write the same
kind of policy.
With the extra space, as
your colleague was saying,
we can just resize down always
to shift these things to be
placed in the middle with a
linear amount of extra space
on the ends.
Does that make sense?
No questions?
All right.
That was a way in which
we had to redefine
an entirely new data structure.
We took the ideas
behind dynamic arrays
and we extended those ideas
to make this thing have
extra space on both ends.
But we kind of had to do
that re-implementation
all by ourselves.
If we were doing code, that
would be kind of gnarly.
But what if someone just
gave us a dynamic array?
What if someone gave
you a Python list,
and you wanted
this functionality?
I don't want to reimplement
a dynamic array,
but I want this
behavior, so how--
any way that I could
do that by reducing
to using a dynamic array--
get this kind of running time?
No?
No one thinks that
we can do this.
This is impossible.
No?
No ideas?
No ideas-- let's say I had--
I have a dynamic array
that's good on one side.
Is there anything I can do
to support dynamic operations
on both sides of a sequence?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Are we able
to just use [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Oh, that's
supposed to be empty, right?
Yeah.
So what your colleague is
saying-- yeah, let's do that.
Let's have one
pointing forwards,
one pointing backwards.
This is the first
of a certain thing.
When we were doing just
a dynamic array here,
where we had to
rebuild everything,
it was important
that we kept track
of where the front thing was so
that we could do time indexing.
As this thing
changed, we would now
have to compute where our
index was in this thing
by adding it to
where the front was.
On this one, we've got
some similar problems.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to divide the
sequence I'm trying
to store up into two sections,
maybe about the same size.
So each of these contains
a linear number of items.
That's how I'm
going to instantiate
my thing with a linear amount
of extra space on both ends.
So now, as I insert
on either side
or delete from either side,
it's going to work just
like a dynamic array.
I have to do some arithmetic
here to figure out where--
if I was trying to
access these items,
I'd have to subtract from
wherever this thing--
I have to do some index
arithmetic, but that's tedious,
but you could do it.
OK.
There's one caveat,
one problem that you
run into in using
something like this.
And what would that be?
Yeah?
STUDENT: I'm not
sure, but you store
things in the second
half of a dynamic array.
JASON KU: In here?
STUDENT: In the first one.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Right.
So what I'm doing
here is actually,
I'm thinking of this
as two dynamic arrays,
but I'm viewing
this one in reverse.
So this is actually the
last of this dynamic array.
Does that make sense?
All right.
So if that's the
situation I'm in, is--
am I done?
Do I have to care
about anything else?
You guys are all
like, we're done,
and I would not give
you full points.
Why aren't we done?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: OK, so what your
colleague is saying is we
somehow got to merge
these into one array.
So we're getting around that
by keeping indexes to here
and being able to do index
arithmetic to kind of simulate
an array underneath.
So we can compute where
these indices should be.
Anyone have another problem
with an underspecified data
structure here?
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] it
could be that [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: I see.
So what your
colleague is saying,
which is exactly correct--
if I were removing
things, removing things,
removing things, I have
nothing else in here.
If I try to pop
from this end again,
I'm going to have to pop from
the beginning of this thing,
which I don't really--
that's going to break
something of what I'm doing.
It's not maintaining
the invariants of what
I want on my data structure.
And so the only caveat here
is that, when I reduce down
to one of these is
empty, what do I do?
STUDENT: You have to cut the
other one in half [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: You cut this thing in
half, move these elements over.
But that's going to leave
these things in the middle
here, right?
The nice thing that
happens here is
I've done a linear
number of options--
operations.
I now have an
amortized cost build-up
that I can spend to now rebuild
the entire data structure.
Does that make sense?
I can now, once I get down
to this thing, take whatever
the remaining things
are, split it in half,
put it into two entirely new
arrays, copy them all over,
and now I've restored my
invariant, where I'm, again,
a linear amount
of operations away
from having to do an
expensive operation again.
Does that make sense?
So while we were able to reduce
to using these dynamic arrays
for a lot of the
cases, we actually
had to do a little bit more
work to make this work out.
That make sense?
OK, cool-- so that's two ways
of approaching problem 3.
In the last little
bit, we're going
to talk about the last problem.
All right, that makes sense.
I'm going to erase this picture,
if that's all right with you
guys.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: What's up?
It's not all right?
Well, too bad-- watch the video.
OK, so problem 4--
also a fairly accessible,
shall we say, coding question--
what we're doing on
problem 4 is we've
got this nice little story
at the beginning, which
is about this woman
Jen and her friend
Barry, who are trying to sell
ice cream to elementary school
kids.
They're basically lined
up at Jen's truck,
and she's like, oh, there's
too many students here.
So she calls up
her friend Barry.
He has another ice cream truck,
parts at the end of the line,
and the students--
what they want to do
is, to make it more
fair, is they're
going to take the
last half of the line,
reverse it to make it more fair.
I don't know.
It's a stupid situation, but
the underlying thing is what
we're doing is-- part
A here is we have--
we're giving you a linked list--
a singly linked list, and
what I want you to do--
the singly linked list--
all it has is a notion
of size, how long it is.
It has a size and it
has a head this list--
it has a size and it has a head.
And this head is a
pointer to a node,
and the node has just one--
two things stored in it.
It has who-- the name of
the child that's there,
and the next pointer
to the next node.
That's what a singly
linked list is.
So node has an item
key and a next pointer.
This next pointer points to
the next node in the sequence.
OK?
And the question is asking, if
we give you a linked list that
has 2n nodes, I want you
to take the last n nodes,
and reverse their order, and
do this to the data structure.
You're not going to return
a new data structure.
You're going to modify
the existing nodes.
And actually, here is--
goes back to your question.
What are we limited to in
how we approach this problem?
What this problem serves as
your algorithm should not
make any new linked list nodes
or instantiate any new non
constant sized data structures.
So it's not like I can write
through this whole thing,
find out where the
n plus 1th node is,
read out all of those
names, store them
in an array somewhere, and
then rewrite them back out.
I'm not allowed to store
more than a constant amount
of stuff outside of
this linked list,
and I'm not able to
make any new nodes.
Essentially, I just have to
probably keep these items
where they are and
move around the nodes.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Can you use
non-constant space
without creating
a data structure?
JASON KU: So if you're
using non-constant space,
you're instantiating some
kind of data structure,
whether it be in an array or--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Sure.
I'm wanting you not to do that.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
So how are we going
to do this problem?
Anybody?
Anyone have approach for how
I might approach this problem?
Yeah?
STUDENT: In order to
get to the second half
you don't have to do
all of that [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Sure.
STUDENT: Could you start--
probably start
counting backwards so
that you can get them
in the back order,
and then meet it in the
middle so [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Interesting.
So there's a lot of things--
let's break this down.
So a lot of times,
when we're asking
you to construct an
algorithm-- a lot of times,
it makes sense to develop
an outline or a game
plan of constituent
parts that you might want
to approach this problem with.
So the first thing that your
colleague over here was saying
was, at some point, we
need to find out where
the middle of this thing is.
Does that makes sense?
So maybe the first thing we want
to do to approach this problem
is, one, find n-th node.
That's the end of the
first set of children.
OK?
Then I have a second
thing that I want to do.
What's the next
thing I have to do?
I have to reverse the
pointers of everything
after the n-th node, right?
OK, so second thing--
reverse, I guess, next pointers
of everything after the n-th
node--
the nodes n plus 1 to 2n.
Does that make sense?
And after I reversed all of
those things, what do I have?
I have a first block.
This points like that.
And now we've got this
thing, and we've reversed
all the pointers like this.
That's after step 2.
Is that what we want?
Yeah?
STUDENT: Step 3
would be [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: So this is my new end.
I'm going to call this
node a, and this node b,
and this node C. So tell
me, in terms of a, b,
and c, what I'm supposed to do.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Quick
question-- how would we
reverse the next pointer?
I get what you're saying, but--
JASON KU: Right.
STUDENT: --to actually
made that happen--
JASON KU: Yeah.
So to actually make that happen,
this thing has an next pointer.
It's pointed to--
pointing to some node.
I'm needing to relink it
to the thing before me,
so I better remember
what was before me
so I can set node b.next
equals the thing before me,
instead of the thing after me.
Does that make sense?
So that would be relinking the--
STUDENT: And then it
disconnects the linked list.
JASON KU: It disconnects
the linked list
possibly temporarily.
STUDENT: Oh, OK.
It's temporary, and therefore,
it still works out [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Well, we have
to relink everything
to make sure it's temporary.
It's very possible, when
you're dealing with linked data
structures, to unlink something
and not have a reference back
to it, and now this
thing is in memory
that your garbage collector
hopefully will pick up.
But if you're writing
in a language that's
not garbage collected, then
that's called a memory leak.
That's no good.
OK, so how do I
relink these things?
This is the picture
that I have right now.
How do I make this into
a linked list, where
it's here and then reversed?
Yeah?
STUDENT: You can link
a to c [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: Yeah.
So I replace this
pointer from a to b
to make it point to
c instead, and then,
whatever my pointer is to b--
from b-- b is reversed--
it's pointing to a--
let's set that equal to none.
So basically, the last
step here is clean up ends.
And in LaTeX
write-up, you'd want
to specify, what are the
things that you're relinking?
But this was a coding
question, and so we actually
gave you code to work with.
So I'm going to see whether
I can live code this for you
in front of you.
OK.
So here was our code
submission site from last term.
And what I have here is my
template from last term, Pset1.
It opens this folder.
It's got a bunch
of things in it,
the LaTeX template
that you have,
and then a bunch of
these Python files.
So I'm going to--
where is it?
Here.
OK, so these are the files
that are in my directory.
I've given you a version of
this linked list sequence.
And then we have two more
code questions-- a tests file
and a reorder_students file.
So reorder_students look
something like this.
It has a template of
the code that we're
going to want you to write,
with inputs and outputs.
And you're putting
your code here.
And this function doesn't
need to return anything.
All right, and then
we also give you
this linked list
implementation, which
is what's in your
recitation handout.
I'm actually going to
ignore most of this stuff--
really just that this thing
contains an item in next
in your node--
I'm not actually going to
look at the items at all--
and a head and size in my
linked list at the top level.
OK?
But this is just to tell
you what's in there.
So that's what's going
to be input to my thing,
and if I go here
and I run the tests
document that you
gave me, it fails
because I don't have anything.
It didn't do
anything to the list.
OK?
All right.
And in fact, if I go into
here to the tests and I--
what is it?
It's reordering
the students here.
I print the linked
list that you gave me.
I'm going to have
a line break here.
What we can see is,
when I do this--
here are my test cases.
Here's a linked list.
And what's happening
is it's just spitting
out the same linked lists.
I haven't done anything to it.
All right, so we need
to do something to it.
How are we going to do that?
All right, so let's
implement this function.
And I'm going to get rid
of this stuff, because--
get rid of that.
All right, so we need
to reorder the students.
So I'm going to break
this up into three parts
that we have here.
We're going to
find the n-th node.
So how do we find the n-th node?
This thing has a size
on it, so let's at least
figure out what n is.
So let's set n equal to--
I think I can use
length, because I've
implemented that on
my thing, and it's
going to be whatever
the length is over 2.
And I'm defined by
the problem statement
that I'm only going
to have even inputs.
And I'm going to set, at first,
my a to be the starting place.
I'm going to just have a little
temporary variable that's
going to say this is going to
be equal to the head of my list.
And what I'm going to do is
what your colleague was saying--
is I'm just going to
loop through n times
until I reach the n-th thing.
Actually, how many
times do I have
to travel through next
pointers to get to node a?
n minus 1, actually-- yep.
So this is going to be for.
I don't care about
this loop variable,
so I'm going to just use
that n minus 1 times.
What am I going to do?
I want to replace a with
the thing it's pointed to,
so I'm going to just walk down
this thing. a equals a.next.
And now, after the end
of this loop, what is a?
a is the n-th node.
I've now made it the
n-th node-- fantastic.
And now I'm going to say that
b is going to be the next one.
Just in terms of my write-up,
I labeled these things
as a, and b, and c,
and so in my mind,
I'm going to want to use
the same kind of notation
here so that I can
understand my code.
OK, so b is going to
be the next thing.
And now, in this process, as
I'm going to flip things around,
what I'm going to
do is I'm going
to keep track of three nodes.
I'm going to keep track of
x, which is the node that I'm
going to be relinking.
And what else do I
need to keep track of?
If I'm--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
destination.
JASON KU: Yeah,
where I came from
and where I'm going
to, because that's what
I'm going to need to relink.
In particular, I'm going to
have someone pointing to me,
which I'm going to
call next previous--
or the x previous.
When I'm going to label it,
it's going to be the next thing.
All right?
Does that make sense?
So in my first situation, I'm--
the first thing I
need to relink is
b, so that's going to be my x.
And x previous is going to be a.
Does that makes sense?
So I'm going to instantiate
those two variables.
x and x_p are going
to be b and a.
Sorry.
That's right.
Yeah.
Maybe it makes more sense to
have x previous and x equal ab.
All right, that's
in the right order.
Either way is fine.
And then I want to
go through a loop.
I'm going to be
doing a loop way.
You can do it a recursive
way, if you want.
Here's a loop way, in
which I'm just going
to loop through how many times?
How many pointers am I going to
relink as I go down this thing?
I need to relink the pointers
of all of these guys.
How many are there?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: How many?
JASON KU: n-- there
are n of them.
So for-- I don't care about
the loop variable here either.
I'm going to do this n times.
And what am I going to do?
I'm going to first figure
out who my next guy is.
I'm going to set x_n
equals what? x.next--
all right, so now I know
who's next to me right,
so I can go there later
after I relink my pointer.
I'm remembering that.
Now, I don't care about what's
stored in x.next, because I've
stored it locally.
That makes sense.
All right, so now I am free
to relink that next pointer
to my previous guy.
And now I can essentially
shift my perspective over,
so the thing that I'm going
to relink now is the next one.
So x previous and x
now equals x, x_next.
Does that make sense?
Just relinked things over--
so that's the end of step 2.
Now, as I got down this at
the end of this for loop,
where is x?
What is x_p, x, and
x_next-- or x_n?
Really, I'm only keeping
track of x and x_p here.
So what are x_p and x
at the end of this loop?
I've done this n times.
I started with b at x.
So what is x?
Yeah?
So we have a vote that x is c.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JASON KU: So this is
a little interesting.
All right.
I will tell you that c
is either x_p, x, or x_n.
So we have one vote for x.
Who says something else?
Eric doesn't like x.
There are only
two other choices.
Does someone say something?
x_p-- I will argue
that it is x_p.
Why?
Because I'm at b.
There are n things.
I did n operations, and every
operation, I move 1 over.
So when I've done n minus 1
things, I'm at c, the n-th one.
Now x is none, because
there's null pointer
at the end of the list.
So x_p is c, so I'm going to
set p equal to x_p, which is--
it's just for me to remember
what these things are.
And I just relink
these two pointers.
a.next should be c and
b.next should be none.
Does that make sense, everybody?
Let's see if we did it right.
So we save that thing and we
run Python on the test cases,
and it did the right
thing apparently-- maybe.
Let's see-- ran
five test cases--
OK.
All right, so let's
take a look at this.
We had this linked list--
Lilly, Sally, Cindy,
Maisy, Sammy, Davey.
And what it turns into is Lilly,
Sally, Cindy, which is correct.
And then it reverses this
last part of the list--
Danny, Sammy, Maisy--
cool, awesome.
But these are the test
cases we gave you.
So let's try this
against our code checker.
So I select the file.
Where do I go?
I think I'm in my desktop here
in session 1, and template,
and reorder students.
I submit it.
Please work.
And 100%-- and now we're
happy, and we can go party.
OK.
All right, so that's
the first problem.
Hopefully this was
helpful to you.
We will release problem set 1
tomorrow, and good luck on it.